okay so loading the bullets in a
tracking point TP 750 rifle the TP 750
is a computer-assisted self aiming
long-range sniper rifle it's targeting
system guarantees almost foolproof
accuracy by firing not when the shooter
first pulls the trigger but instead only
after the barrel is perfectly lined up
with the target so when I push the red
button that's right above the trigger
the crosshairs turn blue so that I can
line up exactly where I want to hit when
I let the red button go the blue
crosshairs will turn the red and when I
then pull the trigger the crosshairs
turn around and the scope will fire when
I manage to line up the shot the $13,000
rifle promises accuracy to even the most
novice shooters but security researchers
Runa Sandvik and her husband Michael
auger have found ways to hack the gun
via its Wi-Fi connection we found that
we could make the shooter mr. Schad
either by just a tiny bit or completely
off living to the point of hitting the
target that's next to the one that the
shooter is aiming for tracking point
rifles offer a Wi-Fi connection that
allows a nearby computer to stream the
video from the scope or even change
settings like wind temperature and
ammunition wait we found a way to
connect directly to the computer that's
inside of it and change the same values
but in such a way that it doesn't show
up in the screen what we're doing now is
we are connected to the back end and we
are changing the weight of the bullet so
that when the scope does the
calculations to figure out when it needs
to fire and what the other settings need
to be for it to hit the tag then it's
going to miss so it's gonna hit the one
on the left instead they're lining up to
take the shot
and there there you go hit the target on
the left almost the center